un club de nueve personas quiere elegir
una mesa directiva compuesta por tres
cargos presidente vicepresidente y
secretario de cuántas maneras se puede
escoger a la mesa directiva de entre los
nueve miembros del club
nosotros vamos a suponer que cualquier
persona que ya sea elegida o haya sido
elegida para ocupar alguno de los cargos
no puede ocupar ningún otro por ejemplo
si yo fui elegido para ser el secretario
entonces no puedo ser ni presidente ni
vicepresidente bien y ya que tenemos eso
en cuenta vamos a pensar en nuestras
tres posiciones tenemos al presidente
presidente
tenemos al vicepresidente vicepresidente
y tenemos al secretario
secretario
bien entonces cuántas personas pueden
ocupar el cargo de presidente pues
tenemos nueve personas en el club así
que cualquiera de esas nueve personas
puede ser el presidente pero ya que una
fue electa para hacer el presidente
cuántas personas pueden ocupar el cargo
de vicepresidente como ya una persona es
el presidente solo pueden serlo
ocho personas ahora bien qué sucede con
el secretario ya se ocuparon dos
personas en los cargos de presidente y
vicepresidente de modo que para el
secretario solo hay siete personas
disponibles y noten que hubiera sido
exactamente lo mismo si hubiéramos
empezado eligiendo al vicepresidente en
vez de al presidente o al secretario
simplemente estos números si hubieran
reacomodado pero vamos a ver que eso no
importa en un segundo porque entonces
cuántas combinaciones tenemos cuántas
mesas directivas pues tendríamos nueve
lugares por el presidente por ocho para
el secretario
7 para él
perdón 8 para el vicepresidente por 7
para el secretario 9 por 8 es 72 y 72
por 7 es 7 por 214 llevamos 17 por 7 49
y una que llevábamos 504 hay 504 hay 504
modos distintos de escoger a la mesa
directiva de entre los nueve miembros
del club